What if you could reverse engineer any
successful YouTuber's content strategy
in 20 minutes and walk away with a list
of video ideas for your niche? I'm going
to show you how to use Claude Code to do
that live today. The YouTuber we're
going to reverse engineer is Nick Sarv.
He runs one of the biggest AI automation
channels on YouTube with over 200,000
subscribers, regularly hitting 50,000
90,000 views on technical videos. I'm in
his school community, Maker School, and
I've learned a ton from his content. But
instead of just watching his videos, I
want to understand systematically what
works for him. Not guessing, data. And
then this is the important part. I'm
going to take the patterns I learned
from his channel and apply them to
content ideas for my own channel.
Research and application. Let's get into
it. All right. The first thing I need is
data. So, let's find Nick's YouTube
channel. There he is. Nick Sarv
YouTube. Okay, there we go. I want you
to download the metadata and the
subtitles of every, let's say, long form
video from Nick's YouTube channel. Um, I
want you to organize it properly and I
want you to create a SQLite database
locally which contains
all the metadata and like well
ststructured information with like well
structured types and everything. Here's
his channel. I want you to create a new
virtual environment using UV to do all
of this. Okay. All right. So, if you're
new to programming, there's a lot that I
just packed into a small space. So, let
me describe now everything I just did.
So, I'm going to pull up Excaladraw. So
the first thing is you'll notice is that
I gave these instructions verbally. So
one important tool when you're building
automations with claude come on. One
important tool when you're building
these automations is
I recommend using a speechtoext
tool like uh Super Whisper or Whisper
Flow because you can just do things a
lot faster. Okay. Now, another thing
that you notice is that I'm asking it to
download the metadata and the subtitles
but not the videos. Okay. So, if you're
analyzing YouTube, you're going to waste
a lot of time if you're downloading the
actual videos. Like, that's not useful.
So, um, ask
Claude code. Can I make this bigger? Can
I zoom in? All right, there we go. But
now, like, do I know how to drag this?
Maybe that. Maybe that. Ah, there we go.
That works. Ask Claude code
to Jesus. ask cloud code to download the
uh subtitles and metadata only. Okay.
Three, the other thing that I asked it
to do was to structure it properly in a
database. And so the way that we're
doing things is first we do all the
scraping, then
we're going to want to do some kinds of
analyses with that scraping. But if we
format our data and get it like ready
for analysis, that's going to make
Claude codes later step a lot easier to
do. And the nice thing is that it's
pretty intelligent. So you don't
necessarily even need to know much more
than just to tell it put it in a
database. Now the reason why I'm
specifying a SQLite database okay so say
put it in a database or like ask claude
code to put it in a database
specifically
SQLite is because SQLite is a database
file format that is just stored in a
single file on your computer and pretty
much every computer is going to have
that like dependency available. Now,
another thing that you'll notice here is
that I asked it to create a new virtual
environment using UV. Okay, so what is a
virtual environment? Um, when you're
using Python, there are different
versions of Python and there might be
different packages that you use in
Python. And so the problem is that when
you have different projects that all use
different versions of Python with
different packages, they can conflict
with each other. And so what is best
practice is for each project to create a
virtual environment. And UV is the tool
which is the most modern most commonly
used for virtual environments these
days. So I asked Sid to create a new
virtual environment using UV. All right.
So now let's see how it's going. Um so
it seems to be in progress.
Okay. It like wrote a script. It found
255 long form videos. Now it's
downloading the detailed metadata and
subtitles for all videos. Okay. So, uh,
right, it's like it grabbed information
about him. So, like let's see. It's it's
downloading all these videos right now.
Um, what else? Yeah, it's in progress.
So, now we're just going to wait for it
to finish its work. All right. So, it
finished. It got 252 metadata files and
502 subtitles files. So, let's take a
look at some of this stuff. It has
created a structure with channels. This
is in the database,
various subtitle data. Oh, it even like
put subtitles as segments in like
separate. It even created like a table
for different subtitle segments,
thumbnails,
videos. It's pretty good. And it even
has some suggested queries here that
it's done. Example queries. Okay, very
good.
Um, I want you to conduct an analysis.
All right. So, now we have a database
and the next thing I'm going to do is
ask Claude Code to create a plan to
analyze Nick's data. So, here's
something that's important. Oftentimes,
for any kind of complex or non-trivial
task, it's a good idea to ask Claude to
make a plan before it actually
implements a plan. So, right now, it
probably also made sense to make a plan
for the scraping task, but I had an
intuition that it would be able to
handle it easily. This is kind of like a
throwaway quick project. But now the act
of figuring out how to make sense of
this data is a little bit more
complicated. So I'm going to um approach
this differently. I want you to create a
plan for
analyzing the database we've just
produced. The goal of this analysis is
going to be to discern
patterns in Nick's content that I can
use to think about what sort of content
to create in my own YouTube channel.
Now, just from prior knowledge, I know
that Nick's content has changed over
time. He sort of grew an audience by
making a lot of content about make. Then
he sort of seged into NADN and then he
like has lots of other types of broader
content on AI automation, success
stories, stuff like that. And my own
goal with my YouTube channel, which I'll
give you the URL so that you can study
the metadata of that YouTube channel, is
to do two things. One is that I want to
help people get better at using Agentic
coding tools whether they're beginners
or very experienced. And my end goal is
going to be to have some kind of paid
community where I give group coaching
something like that. And then the second
kind of goal I have is to just get
myself out there so that I can bring in
clients myself. So um those are my goals
to the extent that that's relevant. Here
is my YouTube channel. So the content
which I've noticed has kind of hit the
most are these clawed code demos and
then also ones in which I give my
opinion quite clearly on what people
should be doing in 2026 like the types
of things they should be working on. In
particular I have a video called don't
learn any in 2026 do this instead which
has seemed to um strike quite a uh has
gotten a fair bit of interest. And so
when you're creating this plan, I want
you to like kind of think about, you
know, maybe we should have sub agents
who are doing things in a uh iterative
way like first sort of getting the raw
descriptive data and then like build we
can build on that raw descriptive data
to um you know do more refined analyses
like at stages. Maybe that's the way to
do it. That's at least what I have in
mind like sort of thinking of this as a
data engineering problem. All right. So
again, like this packs in a lot. And
while this thing is working, let me give
an explanation of what it is that I just
produced. So let's go over here. God
damn it. Can I figure out how to uh hold
space? There we go. Now I can move
around. So I am I'm an economist by
training. I've got my PhD in economics
from Northwestern, but I worked as six
for six years as a machine learning
engineer. And as a machine learning
engineer, I'm working with like gigantic
data systems. I was working at zel where
we had tons of transaction data. And you
have to kind of think about it when you
want the final outcome to be I am
deploying this model which is detecting
fraud for millions of people. there's a
whole set of pieces that goes into it on
route to getting that final outcome of
this deployed model. And so, uh, that's
the way in which I approach something
like this. Like analyzing a YouTube
channel seems like a sort of creative
task, but you can sort of break it into
here's all this preparatory work that we
have to do along the way to get there.
So the initial bit of preparatory work
was just scraping the data but now we've
scraped it and like the way I sort of
envision it is kind of just like how I
would conduct an analysis as an
economist writing a paper. So when you
read an economics paper first like you
need to have like the raw descriptive
statistics
descriptive statistics. So that was part
of the command that I gave here is
um yeah is like first getting the raw
descriptive data to do and then building
on that raw descriptive data to do more
refined analyses. And so that's like
step one descriptive statistics. And
then you know the next step that I sort
of think of when I'm like thinking about
this process is uh when you're
conducting any kind of empirical
analysis you have your own knowledge
that it's just necessarily going to be
embedded into the analysis and it makes
for uh a better end result too. And so
that's kind of what I was doing here
where I like help it along. I'm helping
the AI along cuz I already know some
things about Nick's channel. Like I have
consumed a lot of it. Uh, I've learned a
lot from it. There's things I disagree
with. There's things I agree with. And
so, I have, you know, a sense of that.
And, uh, when it does misspellings like
this, it really doesn't matter. So, you
can just talk and it's going to get the
gist of it. So, this is going to help
the AI. And with Opus, like the AI is
really good. So, it's going to have a
sufficient ability to do this analysis
pretty much autonomously from this
point. And so we see it's like starting
to analyze the subtitle content title
patterns and successful content formats
content evolution. Okay. So the second
step I ask it to do is um oh yeah is uh
and you should like give it give it your
own like ideas of what's important
to look at. I think that you'll
generally get better results if you do
that. All right. So, that's one, two.
Now, let's like what would I say is
three here. Um, oh, yeah. So, I gave it
my YouTube channel and some context of
like what I want it to look at to like
think about the directions I'm going in.
So, I would give it three, give it
context about your own YouTube channel.
Okay.
So that's one, two, and three. And now
it's basically like going through I
guess like right now even in the plan
phase, it's sort of already like doing
some analyses simply to create the plan.
So yeah, let's see. Let's see how this
goes. And so um all right, so the plan
has completed. Let me show you guys the
plan now. So we'll go here CD plans
and we can read this together. So build
a multi-stage data analysis pipeline.
Okay. So here's the analysis pipeline.
descriptive analytics, pattern
recognition, strategic synthesis,
personalized recommendation
can be run by claude code. Um, okay. So,
there is one structural thing which it
sort of failed to understand which was
because of kind of a flaw in my
instruction. I actually uh
don't need you to like execute this as a
series of Python scripts like the thing
which should be making the decisions at
each stage is just clawed code. So maybe
the appropriate thing for us to create
as an output is going to be a clawed
skill which um like we both use
ourselves and which other people can use
to do this themselves because
fundamentally it should be like clawed
which is doing everything. So like what
I want to produce in this repo is maybe
a um like a cloud skill and we can use
the uh I have like a skill in our
context to create skills. So like part
of the plan can be used to use that
skill but then what I'll create in this
repo is both an application of that
skill and the skill itself like properly
formatted just like skills need to be
formatted. All right. So, let me just
describe to you what I just observed and
this is actually a kind of pretty
important point and pivot. So, I gave it
this set of instructions and what claude
code produced in its initial plan like
if we look here at let me see if I can
grab a screenshot of this. It would
actually be useful. Uh yeah. Yeah. [__]
There we go. Okay. So this was like the
initial plan that claude code came up
with. And then I noticed here that it
seemed to be [__] it seemed to be
suggesting like creating a bunch of
Python scripts each of which has its own
output. And so this is a common error
that you may encounter when you naively
are using clawed code to try to automate
something. Some things are best
automated via Python and other things
are not. This is an example of a thing
where if we use Python to do the
automation, then it's going to be some
deterministic code which is like doing
an action. So that could make sense for
the descriptive statistics, but it
probably doesn't make sense for the
patterns or the synthesis because what
you want in order to like find patterns
and to synthesize things is an
intelligence. And so in the past you
would need an analyst or a researcher to
do those kinds of things like patterns
and synthesis, but now claude code is
that very intelligent like being that
should be doing those things. And so I
saw that for these steps it seemed to be
suggesting uh using Python. And so I
pushed back and I was like hold on I
think we're a little bit off base. And
so what I told it to do instead is that
the plan I wanted to create is for us to
create a skill. And the reason I want to
create a skill is because then I'm going
to be able to give this to you guys and
you're going to be able to use it to
like do this same exact thing for your
own context. So again, I've mentioned
this all the time, but I'm going to
bring it up again. Uh what is a skill?
So we go over here to the documentation.
A skill is a set of instructions which
extend Claude's capabilities in Claude
code. And so the extension that we are
going to be making right now is a skill.
We might make a set of skills. I'm going
to see. But a skill whose purpose is to
um automate like the research of a
YouTube channel and the application of
that research to your own context. So uh
this is a little bit of a pivot. It
might make the video a little bit longer
than I initially expected, but the
upside is that you're going to get a
much better, much more usable result at
the end of this. Okay, so it seems to
have
like created the skill itself
and now seems to be using it to like do
all this analysis itself. So that's not
the way in which I would have wanted to
do things. Uh like if I was trying to do
this officially like I'm a lot more
systematic. I'll spend time like looking
at the skill and seeing what it come up
with. And so in fact let me do that
right now. Let's like go into the
directory and take a look at the skill.
And this will be helpful for you guys
cuz it'll give you a pattern of like
what are good things in skills, what are
bad things in skills, etc. So, um I
already see some problems, but we're
going to talk about those later. Um so,
it's basically the set of instructions.
Use this skill. Yeah. When you have a
SQLite database. So, it's assuming
you've already done that scraping your
own channel metadata, clear positioning
for your niche. goals before running.
Gather the database path, your channel
data, your niche, your goals, and then
execute the following four stages
sequentially. Like that's, you know,
generally a good store results mentally.
I don't like that. It should store
results out to a file somewhere so the
next stage is aware of it. Um, pattern
recognition. Uhhuh.
um correlate content type with optimal
duration strategic synthesis. Okay, so
that that makes sense and that's a
common pattern in using large language
models, right? It's like if you want to
do some sort of summary or analysis, you
like create specialized agents which do
a bunch of separate tasks and then you
have some like unifier agent which
combines them. So that's the pattern I
had in mind in stage three. And then
like once you have this sort of created
recommendation then you would want to
apply it. So this is uh actually helpful
for like helping you guys understand
what is the process of creating skills.
So I'm going to make more videos which
are much more explicit about what the
skill creation process is. But it is
pretty iterative. So in this video I'm
just going to try to like get this
working for me and I'm going to give you
the skill so you can use it. So, it'll
be up um over here on
my school server. If I go to school,
yeah, it'll be here in the AIM MBA. I'll
have it in like a classroom section. If
you aren't in this community, definitely
join. You can come here and like ask me
anything you want and I will respond
with, you know, a really long detailed
school. So, here are like two people who
joined and you know, this guy is looking
for AI to program custom client
routines. So, I gave him an answer
there. And then this guy is looking for
advice on building customer service that
doesn't suck. And so, I gave him a
pretty involved response there. Ask any
question, I'll answer it. Um, okay. And
so, it has now created the report. And
so, let's, uh, let's take a look at
this. So, um, I'm going to ask it to
compile it to a PDF. Can you, uh, use
pandock to compile this to a PDF? Make
sure the PDF is like beautiful. So if
you need to do some latte stuff for that
um do that too. I have tech live
installed. Okay. Um let me explain what
I just said. So um often uh cloud code
will create markdown documents but I
like reading PDFs. I'm sure you do too.
It's like easier to read if it looks
nice than Markdown. Though Markdown is
much better for LLMs to be able to write
and read from. So Pandoc is a command
line tool made by a philosopher. It's
really made by a philosopher. in the
Haskell programming language, but it's a
really good um tool for converting from
markdown to other um other formats. So
you can see like all the different
formats. So it can uh convert to. One of
the formats it can convert to is a PDF.
Under the hood, what it's doing for that
conversion is using Latte, which is a
popular document like markup language
for academics. Like any paper you've
ever written read these days is written
in Latte and it allows you to create
like really beautiful precise uh PDFs.
And so Cloud Code can make these PDFs
pretty reliably. And that's what I'm
having to do right now is make me like a
nice PDF that we can read together. All
right. So it made the PDF. Let's take a
look at it. And um yeah, let's see what
it looks like. So here um okay, so
content strategy report competitor your
channel Nick's Nadm content averages 91K
views versus 30K for make. Okay,
interesting.
Long- form courses get 216K average
views. Tentpole content drives massive
traffic. That's interesting. So, maybe
that's like a good idea. I could create
some kind of long form just free course
on clawed code. I like that idea. You
guys probably like that idea, too. Your
references in titles boost performance
80% timely than a signal matters
matters. So that um I mean that
definitely concords with my experience.
Like it's hard to do a full causal
analysis of why this video hit. But I
think that there are other people who
are kind of on the threshold of
realizing that NAN is becoming
increasingly useless like relative to
using a coding tools. So um they
probably hit for that reason. The 2026
probably helped too. Uh let's go back.
Your don't learn opinion format hit.
Yeah, obviously parentheses and titles
increase views 58%. One thing I'll say
about like this whole thing that we're
doing, right, and I'm obligated as a
Northwestern economics trained economist
to like talk about this is is using a
lot of causal language here to describe
things that are correlational. So, we're
not like we are trying to
figure out the causal structure of the
YouTube universe. Like that's my goal
and that's not my only goal because
simply having content that gets a lot of
views doesn't necessarily lead to the
final outcome that you're interested in,
right? There are better kinds of views
than others. Like if I was, you know,
like I don't know, I'm not going to say
that, but like if I was making like some
shitty Tik Tok type content, right? Then
um like that that could really hit, but
that's not going to get me the views I
want. So, we're trying to like balance
these different things together. And you
still have to use your brain when you're
reading this. So, like this this thing,
right? Parentheses and titles increase
views 58%. Like that's not true. What
we're noticing is just that parenthesis
and titles uh have 58% more views than
those that don't. But it is a useful
observation which maybe we can dig into
more to see if there's something causal
there. Okay. So, this is like a general
overview of Nick's channel. His peak
upload month was April 2025. These are
the average views per video growth
trajectory by year. So some initial
experiments, minimal activity, make.com
dominance and then nen pivot plus
explosion content evolution.
Okay. Duration performance. So like he
has five videos which are these
threehour videos and like look at this
one. and it done full course 6 hours
740,000 videos. I would bet that like
some of these really long videos. Yeah,
that's very interesting. What I wonder
is how much planning is involved for
this versus is it like just a video
which he is sort of like he has an idea
and then he's just going through with it
all the way to the end because having
like a super planned out video um that
would be very difficult for me to do,
right? But if it's um if it's like he's
got a credible like outline and then
he's just sort of using his background
knowledge to like go through with it in
a three or five hour marathon session. I
could do that right with cloud code. So
that's useful information for me. So let
me actually tell that to the uh cloud
code and see what it says. Um so let's
uh go back here. Uh so here's something
I'm interested in and I'd like you to
sort of create a different report on
this topic. So, I noticed while I was
reading this um report that you made on
Nick's content that like a lot of the
stuff that he has, which is like sort of
pivotal for him, are these extremely
long threehour videos where he's
basically demonstrating his expertise
all the way to the end on something like
any make whatever agents and so I
probably have that expertise right now
on claude code on codeex and even on
other tools like open code and so a type
of thing that could make sense is to
have something like what he has produced
for those but to um yeah make it make it
like for the things that I'm an expert
in. And so my question is this um like
based on what you can read in the
transcripts and obviously you don't want
to put those full transcripts into your
context. You kind of want to skip around
because uh you'll eat up your context
like really quickly if you just read the
whole thing. But based on what you can
see on some of his like really killer
top videos, does it seem like he has
like a very well-defined outline that's
super meticulous or you know does he
have like a set of topics that he just
talks about like with some kind of
structure for um a long period of time?
And something else that you could do
which might be um actually no that that
would be kind of difficult. So, uh,
forget about that. Just do what I
suggested. And, uh, create a new report
for me and also compile it to a PDF, but
like in a different file. All right. So,
oh, whoops. I didn't create a new report
for me. Uh, but compile it to a
different file. Okay. So, I'm going to
keep reading this thing while that thing
is sort of going in progress. But let's
let's look around, right? Um, oh, this
is good patterns and top performers.
Comprehensive courses with time
commitment and title. Okay. So, I could
do Yeah, I think I'm going to do
something like this, but I might do it
um this is like a really good SEO one,
right? So, I could ask it to like think
of, you know, kind of more SEO targeted
videos. Um, an ultimate beginner's
guide. Like that's I'm sure that Yeah, I
could do um build your first web app
with clawed code in 3 hours. Ultimate
beginner's guide. [__] yeah. [__] yeah.
All right, we're going to [__] do
that. Hell yeah. All right. Um, make.com
but for people who want to make real
money.
Claw.com, but for people who want to
cloud clown I don't I can't I can't do
that. Ah, the nine best ways to scrape
any website in Nen. You [__]
know it's coming. The nine best ways to
scrape any website in Claude Code.
[__] yeah.
My name Borat. Okay. Bottom 10 videos.
What fails? All right. Nick Sarv, this
is what makes you a failure. Seven
figure agency hire book. Nobody gives a
[__] So yeah, basically nobody gives a
[__] on how much money he makes, huh?
Like 92K per month. Oo, big big big boy.
Making more money than I make, for sure.
[laughter]
Uh, the theory of constraints and how it
earned me $2.4 million. Maybe that's a
new video. I don't know. I actually
remember seeing a video about this by
the scaling with systems guy, Ravi Abua.
Um, I like that guy too a lot. Oh, maybe
I'll do a a video stealing from him. Um,
yeah. Okay. So, based on Nick's data,
allocate your content. Okay. So, like
the cloud code, deep dives, opinionated
takes. Nick's what I' your viral hit.
Nick's what I'd learn instead got 321K.
Which one's ah what I'd learn instead of
automation in 2026. It's true. So like
uh the thing that I was saying on NN
like that video it probably like some of
the things which made that video hit are
probably similar to what make this video
hit. Yeah. Um
okay. And then optimal formats
uh timing and trends. Nick pivoted nod
in early 2025 when it was emerging your
position for cloud code. Okay. So, like
this um this other one, this other
analysis just came up, but I'm going to
finish reading this one first. Um 20
plus video ideas. Bro, this is really
good. Boring Claude Code projects that
will make you 3K. How I built a 10K a
month consulting business with Claude
Code.
Yeah. How this PhD uses [__] yeah. Cuz
this one is actually true. So, like this
is kind of interesting sauce for you
guys, but I've been getting together
with a bunch of my friends who are
faculty economics professors at like top
universities, okay? And but they're like
really behind on Agentic Coding. I'm at
the cutting edge of this [__] So, we've
been getting together and doing sort of
pair programming where we try to write
papers with Agentic Coding tools and the
results we get are absolutely [__]
insane. It's crazy. So, like um this is
going to be me. All right. I'm going to
make this video this year. I guarantee
it. But I don't like making videos until
I actually can back it up. So, I'm I'll
make that video. You guys watch. I'm
gonna I'm gonna be teaching people at
Zapier how to use Cloud Code. Those
[__] [laughter] All right,
let's keep going. Uh, title templates. I
like it. Like, look at this. How much
money would you have to pay some like
[__] YouTube strategist to make this
video? I love it. This is better than I
expected. Key queries used, bro. This is
This is amazing. All right. Like let's
Okay, so now here I asked Claude Code to
actually study Nick's transcripts like
the transcripts of his like his content.
Okay, so let's let's take a look at
this. Um, let's go. Where was it? Uh,
okay. Nick's long form courses follow a
hybrid structure, meticulous chapter
planning combined with conversational
delivery. He doesn't read from a script.
He speaks naturally within a pre-planned
framework. His courses are project
driven, not lecture driven. What does
that mean exactly? So like I actually
haven't watched any of his courses. Like
it was very interesting. Like Nick kind
of sold me on his stuff without me
engaging with a lot of his content. Like
I just sort of could tell that he knew
about the business side and that's where
I wanted help. Not really on the
technical side. Um okay. The highest
performing courses are fewer meteor
chapters. Okay. So that's really good.
It extracts it the chapters. So,
introduction, the NAN basics,
foundational concepts, JavaScript
functions, setting up self-hosting.
Yeah. So, I could definitely do this for
like I could do one for cloud code. I
could do one for codeex, do one for
cursor, could do one for open code.
Yeah, I'm going to do this. Yeah, this
is coming soon. These like this like big
big course delivery style analysis from
transcript analysis. Next delivery
characteristics opening hook pattern.
Hey, welcome to the most comprehensive
NATO end course on how to go from zero,
somebody that's never used this platform
to hero, a master. Yeah, starts with
hey. Hey guys. Hey there. Hey.
Immediately states a transformation
promise using zero to hero framing.
That's right. You [__] are zeros. I
am the hero. I am the hero here. Was
that Indian or Russian? Was it Indian or
Russian? Who knows? Mention monetization
angle within 30 seconds. That's right.
We're making money. Can't say the B-
word. Uh, we're making money, boys.
Boys. Transition pattern
characteristics. Teaching pattern
characteristics. Very good. Uh, live
building approach. Explicit promise to
build live. So, instead of teaching
concepts,
my goal is I don't just want to talk
about stuff. I want to show you. I think
I did that. So, you should give me a lot
of views and a lot of money because I
did that too. And so, if Nick Har did
it, it's good enough for him. It's good
enough for me. your claw code blue.
There we go. All right. Now, like it
even tells me how to make this video
myself. Recommended structure.
Okay. Yeah. Live build real project.
I like it, bro. I like this so much. And
this is going to be so fun for me
because I love like I love doing this,
you know. So, yeah. I I am so excited to
do this. I am so glad I made this video.
Wow. Based on Nick's approach, don't
script word for word. Record in long
takes. Use casual openings, chapter
markers.
Yeah, dude. Awesome. I love it. Okay.
Um, that's a wrap for this video, guys.
I think that was a pretty cool
experiment. Like, you saw the quality of
that result. Okay. Are you going to make
a [__] N workflow that produces this
in however many minutes this ended up
taking? [__] no. This is way better. So,
uh, everybody join, um, what do you call
it? What did I call this thing? The AI
MBA. Did you like that title? AIM MBA.
Join the AIM NBA. Um, ask a question
about whatever. We got like a good group
growing in here. Let's make it even
bigger. Let's, uh, let's get it going.
Uh, boys and girls, girls and boys. I
want everybody in here. Uh, too many
boys now. Let's get some girls in here.
And, uh, yeah, I want to teach you guys
about cloud code and CEX because this is
the future. This is not the future. This
is right now. This is the right now. Um,
so thanks and hope to see you guys soon.
Like and subscribe.